hi I'm Ryan and tonight you're gonna get
to see a special edition episode again
tonight you're gonna get a special
episode where you see two trailers the
Superbowl trailer for Captain America
the Winter Soldier and that one is the
teaser trailer for the second trailer
we're in a good day and age where we're
watching trailers for trailers I really
like this world were in now remember
there was a time when trailers were rare
and you would just like go to the movies
and oh my god they're playing this
trailer now it's like it all gets
released on the internet but ya missed
those days but then again I want to be
able to would do my little trailer
reactions here so yeah [ __ ] those days I
promise this the this amigo of mine that
I would give a shout-out to him his name
is miles Parkinson or partisan or
Parkinson's disease something like that
miles and I we tend to have long
conversations on YouTube even on the
facebook.com slash real rejects account
I am NOT promoting it but you should
totally look like the beige we talk a
lot and yeah he said that you know if
I'm gonna give him a shout-out it should
be on this trailer well dude you're
getting shoutout for two trailers miles
Parkinson's disease I think you could
call that a lot in school and I am so
sorry dude we don't joke like that yet
but that is how I would joke with you in
real life apologize but yeah you're a
cool dude love you come on the show
sometime anyway let's get this trailers
on the road that kind of makes sense cuz
trailers on the roof Super Bowl this bad
boy with Chris Evans looking sexy
[Music]
Maggie
god Bless America and its terrorists
[Music]
and the wolf [ __ ] up
go to foxsports.com to see the world
premiere of the new trailer I don't know
why I was barely anything but it's
giving me chills and it's a damn good
teaser trailer for the next trailer the
actual one the one we've all been
waiting for
well what the hell
that's what when our soldier means Hoku
logo does that hire me
to build a better world sometimes means
turn going down yeah
[Music]
Oh Nick Fury you're gonna die they're
probably gonna question whether or not
Nick Fury is trustworthy again oh [ __ ]
that was awesome
he's barely in his suit
oh right he's got a black friend
[Music]
nice damn Scarlett Johansson's so sexy
he told me not to trust me
this is how everything goes
all new
that's when he answers Nick Fury in the
elevator
those trailers like showing you all the
action
yeah just keep ruining more IMAX [ __ ]
love watching movies on IMAX dad looks
better than the first one by far I
cannot wait to watch that movie it looks
just so badass you know and like
honestly wasn't a big fan of the first
Captain America and I kind of liked it
i mor just liked it then liked it now
haters start commenting below on that
one no this film looks [ __ ] badass
dude Chris Evans manages like the whole
darker thing because you know that's the
secret ingredient to any sequel reboot
or remake just go darker see look at how
more intense this [ __ ] is but anyway
yeah darker better feel like I could
make a black joke here